and you should be live chairman thank
you
thank you good evening and welcome to
the strategy and resources committee
meeting
on tuesday the 28th of january 2021
my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of the committee
this meeting has been held under
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april 2020 in response to
the covered 19 situation
and there are some meeting
organizational issues that i need to go
through
can i please ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your
microphone removes remains muted when
not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being streamed live and
recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to be recorded members and officers
during each item please use the hands up
function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
i will then invite you in the order that
is indicated
via teams i would like to remind you
that apart from indicating points of
order
or that you have to leave the meeting
please do not use the chat function for
any other purpose when speaking
and please ensure you reference a page
number and paragraph number
and as there are a lot of items on the
agenda please try to keep your
contributions
as clear and concise as possible
i would now like the officers taking
part in the meeting at this moment in
time because we may have officers
who join us later as required to
introduce themselves
starting with mr leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr leslie mr dodson
good evening paul dodson director of
strategy performance and governance
thank you mr dodson mr holmes good
evening richard holmes director of
service delivery
thank you mr holmes uh mrs green
she may not be here yet good evening
members um it's
so green on the customers community
and casework manager thank you sue mr
sweetly
good evening members i'm miss hannah
wheatley um specialist services manager
thank you mr sweetly mr butcher
good evening members steven butcher
commercial manager thank you mr butcher
it's uh mr portus
good evening members lance porteous
lead finance specialist thank you mr
portis
mrs cardy
good evening members i'm annette carty
resources specialist services manager
thank you mrs cardi mr morell
chairman do i think he's with us yet
okay look uh i'm miss bird
thank you chairman good evening members
tara bird committee services officer
thank you
okay are there any officers that are
here at the moment that haven't
introduced themselves tara
and no chairman i believe that's
everybody okay
and mr wilslow
sorry that's all right uh yeah um hello
members
um my name's uh matt winslow i'm the
strategy policy and communications
manager
thank you mr leo um this is cardi
um just to uh introduce debbie
um is on the call debbie white and
she'll be answering
any procurement questions you may have
okay
thank you mr cardi
good evening members i'm debbie white
lead specialist for procurement
hello debbie thank you very much
okay i think that's everybody isn't it
yes gentlemen i believe so sorry about
that that's okay that's okay
uh before i call on the clerk to take
the roll call of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
counselor fleming
good evening councillor fleming uh
councillor anne howe
good evening councillor hall
good evening uh brittany morris here
get in councillor morris
i think that's all the additional ones
that we've got
and we've got apologies uh from alasdair
that his wi-fi is playing up at the
moment so
he is here but he's having issues with
wi-fi
uh may have any apologies for absence
please tara
uh yes tell me do you want me to just
call the roll call of the other members
of the committee
for you as well yes please yes yes
if you could just indicate if you're in
attendance please starting with council
mrs channel please
um yes i'm here tara thank you very much
cancer durham president taran thank you
good evening members councillor edwards
president tara good evening good evening
thank you councillor helm
good evening president tara thank you
councillor lagan
yes good evening tyler good evening
members good evening everybody i'm here
evening thank you councillor siddles
here
councillor um good evening tara good
evening chairman good evening members
and officers thank you very much and
council mrs stiltz chairman is attending
as a substitute for cancer schemes
who we have apologies from good evening
uh chairman good evening members
i'm president thank you casa swain yes
yes good evening thank you good evening
council mrs thompson
yes president tara good evening everyone
thank you
and chairman council ms white we believe
we've been advised we'll be joining the
meeting a bit later on
yeah okay thank you very much thank you
very much
so we now move on to item two which was
apologies for absence uh counselor
durham
you just raised your hand chairman i did
yeah thank you um
my my dinner has just been delivered to
me so
i will turn my video off while i consume
that thank you just to later i i
enjoy your dinner and thank you for
informing us thank you you're welcome
okay so i moved now to item agenda
number three which is the minutes from
the 19th of november 2020. uh
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 19th number
found on pages 7-16
are approved as a true and accurate
record i say move
and if you wish to second that motion
please unmute your microphone now and
state your name please
second councilor swains thank you
council this way
if any members wish to raise a matter of
accuracy please use the hand up function
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
before the meeting i was informed by
councillor morris
who has notified me that he was in
attendance at that meeting but he isn't
noted as being in attendance so could
that amend him
please be made tara
and yes of course chairman apologies for
that i'm missing that off we'll get that
sorted thank you
thank you very much are there any other
items of accuracy
no okay uh
can i ask committee to agree those by
ascent
agreed agreed great
thank you very much i now move on to
item four
which is the minutes from the 24th of
november
a special meeting of strategy resources
it is recommended that the minutes of
the special meeting
held on the 24th of november found on
pages 1720
and as you can imagine i'm not going to
go through those pages in turn
are approved as a true and accurate
record a so
move and if you wish to second that
motion please unmute
and state your name now second
councilors wayne thank you councillor
swain
if any member wishes to raise a matter
of accuracy
please use the hand up function
okay uh can i take that
that we agree those minutes by ascent
i now move to agenda item number five
which is disclosure of interest
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary
interest other pecuniary interest
or non-pecuniary interest relating to
items of business on agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive
of the code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the needs arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest occur please use the hands
up function now
and the first person i have is penny
channel counsel china
um thank you chairman um that's my
normal one chairman i'm going to declare
that
it's non-pecuniary i'm a member of essex
county council
and obviously varying bearing in mind
the various documents and
and that and how we work with essex and
other matters and essex is mentioned and
also we'll declare chairman
certainly um regarding the capital
strategy and other documents
it does refer to it there's a project
there and
um i will declare i'm a member of the
crouch harbour
um advisory committee um and
therefore um there is a vessel mentioned
and also
um in the papers about houseboats and
things so i'm going to declare that in
the past i've always removed my
self from meetings when the least helic
and mata surrounding it has been
discussed
i think i can remain in the chamber
because obviously there's
things have moved on there but i
probably may not comment if that
item gets under too much discussion um i
didn't speak to haven't had a chance to
speak to the monitoring officer but
it's a non-pecuniary thing it's and i've
always kept myself out of discussions at
the crouch harbour
advisory committee when um that vessel
might have been discussed
so that's why i feel i can remain yeah
thank you councillor china
council logan
thank you chairman uh like to declare a
non-pecuniary interest in agenda item
number seven please
um i've had conversations with several
other business owners in the past
and uh was a previous barge owner and
operator
okay non-particularly chair thank you
okay thank you council logan
council durham uh thank you thank you
chairman uh declaring non-binary
interest as a member of essex county
council
um and in respect of um item 21 on
tonight's agenda i'm chairman of visit
essex
but that again is non-pecuniary it's
just uh in the interest of openness
openness and transparency thank you
thank you counselor could i ask all
counselors once they've
made their point to lower their hands
please uh councillor stilts
thank you um mr chairman
i'd like to declare non-pecuniary in
item seven
as i also know some of the barge owners
i'm also a member of the
malden heritage harbour association
and the little ship club in case that's
uh
comes up okay thank you councillor silts
councillor edwards
yes chairman thank you um i would like
to declare an interest non-binary item
seven i'm a member of the thames
uh barge trust thank you okay thank you
council edwards
so that i believe is all uh interests
that have been shown and they're no more
hands up so i now move on to
item number six on the agenda and that's
public participation and i can advise
that we have not received
any submissions from members of the
public
so now we move on to agenda item number
seven
discretionary fees and charges 21 22
discussion fees and charges found on
pages 121
to 144 shortly i will call on the
officer to present these items
members i will just say this reminder
once
and that is if you wish to speak on this
item and any other item
please make this known by using the
hands up function within this meeting
once you've made that your point and
you've
asked your question that made your
statement can you please ensure
that you lower your hands once you've
done that so councilor edwards could you
please lower your hand
i will then come to you in turn keep
please your points clear and succinct
mr leslie please present the report
thank you chair this is the annual fees
and charges set in report uh for next
year
and uh the detailed fees and charges are
in the appendix
obviously to assist members we have also
included
an appendix b which i believe to be on
page 143
a summary of those changes but hopefully
it makes it
easier to understand all the details
contained within there
obviously following a meeting of the
finance working group
we've also included at recommendation
to consideration for reductions of
the wolfage charges
there thank you thank you mr leslie
and before we move to the recommendation
what i would like to say at this
particular moment in time
is the finance working group was a new
working group
and i would just like to thank all the
members of that working group for the
hard work
along with the offices that they've put
in over the last few months
around the finances and around to come
into this meeting today
and i would like to thank all the
officers and all the members for their
contribution
in terms of uh where we've got to this
evening
now the recommendations i will put those
i will put those for a second
however that has no influence in terms
of yeah what we decided to buy we'll put
the recommendations
before we have the debate and the
recommendations
to the council item little one
that the detailed fees and charges for
2122
has set out an appendix aid be agreed
subject to recommendation little two and
little two is
the options for warfaring fees outlined
in section 4
of this report are considered and a fee
agreed
to be put forward to the council
if any member wishes to second that
motion please unmute your microphone
yes second thank you very much this way
i will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
council lagan
thank you chair i was just removing my
hand uh so that i don't it's remissively
afterwards
um with chair and members it's kind of
no surprise that
i wish to speak on this um in simple
terms i
i wish to support the 50 reduction for
the barge owners for warfight costs
um i've done significant amount of
research and obviously
as i've declared being an ex barge
operator
um malden is is synonymous with the
thames alien barges
and these historic and very beautiful
vessels that have donned our paperwork
our crests uh and have brought so much
to our town
um are under threat this has been a
terrible situation with kovid
it's impacted everything and especially
the business owners and the trusts that
are trying to operate down there
and i feel that this council or this
committee has within its power to
to make a recommendation of 50 percent
um
it seems a lot of money to be able to
say we we we're going to take out of our
budget because of
of the the pressures that are upon us
budgetary
but last year we we had one barge leave
the key
because of the increases in warfage fees
another vessel
was placed upon the blocks so it wasn't
paying off each fees
um that's a significant reduction in sum
of income
one more barge would completely wipe out
a 50
of what we could potentially get so by
encouraging the vessels to remain in
malden
by supporting the vessels to continue
their businesses
which is compounded by a document that i
located from our website a report from
morton district touring
tourism strategy ebo29a
which talked about a market overview
about the cost of tourism
what it brings into our our town and
this
document stated that the economic impact
we had 2.96 million visitors and 1.41
million
of income from the district was raised
and it then clearly says
on page number three of that report that
tourism products
and it's i'll just quote this before i
finish it's very short
it says the product strengths include
the barges and the boats
the key and the historic quaintness of
the town
so i feel i can't i can't add any more
to that
i feel it'll be remiss of us if we
didn't support with a 50
increase and then maybe look at cpi
increases over the next three years with
review at that time
so i wholeheartedly support the 50 and i
hope this committee sees that this is
the right thing to do
going forward for the future thank you
councillor thompson
thank you chairman sorry for the delay
likewise i'm just removing
um i've got a query through you please
for offices i understand that
these barges are already receiving a 50
percent
discount on their portage and other
businesses using the wall
don't uh which i think many of them
weren't aware of
um at the previous point in the past and
uh
we're not necessarily very happy about
so um could i have confirmation about
that particular point before i say
anything else please
mr leslie could you clarify exactly what
whether there is any discount currently
on on the barge warpage
uh yeah i don't believe there is but uh
i'd like to refer
uh perhaps to the service who might be
able to
confirm or correct me
mr holmes
thank you chairman um there are a range
of discounts uh depending on the
location of vessels and where they come
from i don't have that
uh detail to hand mr butcher is also on
the call he may have that um if not i'll
have to come back to you but
yeah there is some differential um but i
can't give you these exactly so i'm
afraid
okay thank you mr holmes uh
so can we see if mr butch can find those
figures and
if i move on to councillor durham
thank you very much chairman chairman
obviously
you know with my visit essex hat on
tourism is absolutely vital to the
district and as it's vital to
to the county i mean in a normal year
tourism and hospitality puts three
billion pounds a year into the essex
economy
and you know clearly as councillor lagan
has said
the barges are synonymous with uh the
molten district
and it would be a great shame to lose
them but i'm a little bit nervous
about creating a precedent just for the
barges if we reduce the fee for the
barges
uh you have the kiosks for example on
the prom park who have suffered from
this in this pandemic equally as much as
the barges and lots of
other businesses and you know it'd be
very difficult to justify
cutting the warfage fees down for them
and then not doing the same
for uh the kiosks and and any other
service that we've got and i'm not
trying to be a killjoy i'm not trying to
to to make life difficult for the barge
owners but i think by
taking this step it's it's a little bit
it's a little bit
um it's not even handed um you know
clearly every pound that we take is is
important and it would be tragic to lose
the barges but i'm more concerned
about the the signal that this sends out
to
other businesses that pay the district
council a fee
thank you very much okay thank you
councillor durham councillor china
sorry i found a bit of digging in my
mute here again
um yes thank you chairman um in fact
councillor thompson and councillor dumb
has
raised points that i i was actually
going to be making and i
think councillor thompson might be
correct i do seem to recollect something
about the barges already
having a discount and i seem to
recollect
um the previous leader at some stage
actually
meeting with the barge owners and i
thought there may have been
a slight increase in uh
their warfage fees in
i think um perhaps the budget of last
year
but obviously officers um need to
confirm that but i am
i am following my memory like counselor
thompson
in that i seem to recollect there was a
discretion
already applied um in terms of
the barges but i do agree they are
iconic and they're very very important
however
you know um i could see perhaps other
um sort of approaches people might feel
same about their own sort of
vessels or other areas as well which
could then
obviously create uh a bit of a difficult
situation possibly
okay thank you councillor turner uh yeah
from
in terms of my point of view i would uh
ascend to council lagoon and that is
that the barges mean malden molten means
the barges
and therefore we have to support uh the
barges and we
and what they mean to malden uh we did
at s r just over a year or so ago look
at the bar
the the fees and at that particular
point there was a proposal to increase
the warfare fees over time um
what we decided at that particular point
from what i can remember is that we
decided that we would give us more rise
and then then not to increase those
those fees um after we've had
discussions with the barge owners
now we're now in exceptional situations
and because the barge owners do not have
the same kind of
uh situation as a as a business and a
business premise they haven't been
receiving the discount that other
businesses perhaps have done
and my view is that we need to be seen
to be supporting
what molden stands for and ensuring
that we send the right signals to the
district to the town
and to the barge owners that we are
prepared to support our maritime
heritage
and what the barges mean to malden
councillor swain
thank you chairman um yes i think
uh any concessions that were made last
year were fairly
minor um and as you say it was in the
context of an attempt to
actually increase fees um
i i don't i think as i think you've just
intimated they are in a different
position
um the kiosks are commercially
competitive operations um
and that's quite different from um the
situation of the barges
where we don't have people competing to
try and get a birth in
in malden um in fact what we would like
to do is
to try and encourage one or two more to
come
um and that could only be done by making
the
wolfage fees um which we say attractive
enough
uh and bearing in mind that that we also
have
charitable trusts running these um
as exceptions um as uh
as i think we all realize um the barges
are
uh fundamental really to uh not only to
the image of malden but they're actually
going to be a corner piece
of any developing strategy to make
more of the maritime heritage
and around the hive as mr butcher
could um probably validate
um they are would be rather unique
really particularly if we have a visitor
center there for maritime purposes
in being actually sort of working museum
pieces um which is rather unusual
and i think if we make a concession of
this whatever 25 50 percent um the
difference is not great
in this great overall scheme of things
we should see it more
in terms of um
part of the promotional budget for the
district
rather than as a an expense saving or
expense um concession
um in order to uh underwrite law and
rate underwrite the position of the
barges in in
as a centerpiece really of the um
maritime promotion for malden
thank you councilman i would certainly
support the 50
reduction thank you councillor uh before
i go
back to councillor thompson uh because i
have now a response from
mr butch and mr butcher
yes thank you chairman uh um just for
clarity i've just
scrambled back and looked at previous
snr committee report from
uh december 2019 so um
as other councillors alluded to yes
there was a previously a 50
discount applied um with effect from
april
2020 we started charging a new baseline
figure of 3575.
that was the um that was the figure paid
in 2019-20
plus a 10 increase so in real terms
there's still
um a 40 discount on in comparison to
other wolfage fees
okay thank you mr butcher uh councillor
helm
oh sorry cancer thompson sorry oh thank
you chairman
i did put my hand up with you mentioned
my name um
yes i i wasn't actually sure whether the
current discount was 40
or 50 because i had lost track of what
happened with the 10 percent that was
previously discussed but
mr butcher has put us uh clear on that
one
um yes of course i support the barges
but they aren't the only thing that
makes mold and i think
i would be very happy to continue
the discount as it is but i it does
concern me
because of fairness to others um
the thing about the barges is they can
up and off at any time and and
i'm i've been on the couch long enough
to remember being
bitten by the dawn which we as a council
sunk large amounts of money and massive
amounts of officer time into
um and after all that they uh moved to
kent
so i mean the barges can move at any
time they might have a business need to
move
i would have thought actually the thing
that affected the barges use of malden
key more than anything would be the lack
of dredging
which i know is a whole other story but
i
i understand they have more and more
difficulty with every passing year
actually accessing the key
at the times they would really like to
because of the
lack of depth of water anyway thank you
thank you thank you council thompson uh
council helm
thank you very much mr chairman
councillor thompson has mentioned
something i was going to mention
if we reduce the fee by 50 who's going
to pay for the dredging are we going to
expect it to pay for that as well
i i i will be cleaning out so they can
access it
and if we want more barges we've still
got to dig it out so
your catch 21 here although i want to
support the barges
we need to support then all tourist
operations involved because they're all
important
thank you thank you council helm uh i
will go to councillor fleming
thank you chair
[Music]
chance of flowing on mute sorry
um i just a couple of members have
uh referred to the impact of covert on
the
barge operators i just wanted to ask mr
leslie whether
they are eligible to apply for the
discretionary grant
and if indeed some of them have thank
you thank you council fleming
do you have that specific detail mr
leslie
yeah we've had um some of not
specifically for those ones but
i can talk generally about wolfage in
the sense that some
are eligible to pay
business rates um that's on the on the
moorings
um therefore if they meet the criteria
and they pay the business rates then
um and meet the eligibility criteria
then some of them can do
i know some of uh some have i don't know
exactly to hand which ones have but i do
know some have
okay thank you mr leslie
uh i'm now going to go to councillor
white
um thank you mr chairman i'm sorry i was
late this meeting but i got held up on
the way home from the office and
just to echo on from what councillor
helm said
um although i support the barges and the
bigger problems are with the dredging
and in actual fact i raised this with
brb recently um about dredging as part
of
um the rebel power session if it goes
ahead
and for me this is something that we
should be progressing
more than trying to claw back the
charges because i understand we'll
reduce the charges anyway
and i think those that can uh can claim
the
um money back from the council i'm sure
we'll be doing so
so i would say i think that to help the
barges further more than short-term
reducing the
fees is to actually look forward to
options where we can help them long-term
and to do the long-term sustainability
which basically where
what we should be doing is protecting
our assets and that for me is part of it
so
i would just like to ask the committee
that we start you know progressing talks
on this um
on this matter if we're not already
doing it thank you councillor white
uh council durham i noticed that you've
raised your hands again so
i i will bring you back but if you could
be really succinct please
it's it's a question the the under
warfage there are lots of different
categories
um static events etc etc and indeed
warfighter burnham now
way of getting around this partially
because it does refer to the fully
rigged 10 sailing barges which is
actually what we're worried about
if if we um hold all of the other
charges under warfage
at the same rate and just reduce that
for the
the the qualifying fully rigged them
sales barges
that i think might be a um a halfway
house that would be
certainly more acceptable thank you okay
thank council durham council logan again
if you can be succinct please
oh your hand's gone so you don't you're
not coming back cancer lagging
okay yes sir sorry i just hit the hand
to get so i don't
interfere with the protocols just thank
you for letting me come back and very
succinctly i'm
i'm amazed by the knowledge of normal
members to do with the modern dredging
and how barges sit
um i'm pleased that we have that
knowledge here
um but i also i won't want to go on the
the aspects of the past um we're
debating this situation we're not
debating whether brb build a power
station or not
we're debating a reduction of a daily
income of 29 pounds and 38 pence
if we choose to support businesses that
are very very difficult to
to to actually raise and generate money
you don't see their barge owners in big
houses and big cars
okay thank you councillor and councillor
swain again if you're coming back please
be succinct
and yes i think the comments about um
dredging are very appetizing but i think
that is something quite separate that we
do need to look at and it's a much more
complicated um
uh issue um but it obviously has a
bearing upon the usability of the wharf
um which is really reflected in the lack
of time that um
barges have a level um i would
definitely like to propose that we
do um uh recommend to council
50 reduction before we come to that i i
will go to councillor china first
uh thank you very much chairman um could
i just ask because i notice appendix b
and it did say no change ovi all the
fees and charges
actually do have listings of um i
presume officer recommendation obviously
clt would have considered i suspect
no doubt finance working group um
and the warfight fees is on there and
says no change and it's also not
deemed sensible to try and raise at this
particular time so we were talking about
freezing the charges can i just ask
mr leslie i've heard what you've said
about some of them has anyone
um you know was there a suggestion in
finance working group at all that
someone should go and discuss anything
with the the barge owners at all
has anyone been down and had a
conversation with the barge owners
officer or member wise um for discussion
because i do recollect in the past as i
said and i'm glad it's been clarified
they have already
the uh well we've now learned it's 40
obviously because there's the 50
and then the previous leader met with
them and had a discussion
and at that time it seemed to be that
there was an amicable agreement
my understanding i can see councillor um
nodding no
but that is my recollection and that's
what went through at the last budget so
i just see
some qualifications on dialogue with the
barge owners from
the authority really thank you council
so uh i i know
that uh from my discussions at the
finance working group and what we talked
about
was that uh mr butcher and i also
sort of put forward myself that yeah
another representative to go and speak
with the barge owners um as far as aware
i don't think that's happened in that
particular time
i remember from the discussions at
strategy and resources that we had uh
in december and and after that that
there had not been positive discussions
there had not been
uh constructive discussions between the
barge owners and the leader of the
council at that particular time
um so that wasn't the case and i don't
think it's relevant to what we're
discussing this evening
so uh i would now like to move forward
with the recommendation
and i am going to put forward in terms
of the the forty fees
that we do offer a 50 discount
for the barges uh for this financial
year can i have a second to please
secretary councillor lagan please on a
recorded vote please chair
okay uh so we've now moved to the
recorded vote
so the recorded vote is that uh we are
doing the two things together so item
one that the fees and charges for 2122
are agreed and that the recommendation
that the warfight fees outlined in
section four
are discounted by 50
tara could you do the vote please if i
might just come in how long is the
reduction period for because that wasn't
clear in the recommendation
for that for this financial 2122
[Music]
uh thank you chairman members um if you
could just indicate if you're fought
against or abstaining when i call your
name please
and starting with councillor mrs channer
so this just so just clarify
it's for the recommendations as in the
report but with the 50
discount for uh the wharfage
that's right
yes thank you i will abstain and when we
get to obviously the 23rd of february
i think some of the things might be a
bit clearer in terms
of in terms of this because councillor
dharam made some very good points
okay thank you council channel we are
just doing the vote
thank you council dharam i'm staying
thank you
thank you councillor edwards paul
thank you council helm upstairs
lagoon football please tara
councillor four
stamp
oh thank you cancer mrs stilts
counselor swain four
mrs thompson abstain
counselor
the results of that recorded vote are
six four nobody against and four
abstentions
thank you very much thank you tara
so uh we now move on to item number
eight which is the
treasury management strategy for 21 22.
uh mr council helm if you could lower
your hand please as we've moved on from
that previous item
mr leslie could you please present the
report
so the treasury management strategy is
required to be approved
annually and set out how the council
manages its cash flows
its core elements remain unchanged from
last year
the council's external treasury advisors
advisers
are in close have reviewed the strategy
and provided some of its
content particularly around the economic
outlook
the code of practice on treasury
management lists 12
treasury management practices and how
the council
addresses these is set out in appendix 2
of the report thank you mr leslie
uh so i now need to move on to the
recommendation and the recommendations
as set out in the report
are as follows to the council that the
treasury management strategy 2122
appendix one be approved if a member
wishes to second that motion please
unmute your microphone second
thank you very much councillor swing
i will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
i have no hands up so i will
take that that we have agreed the report
by ascent can i have that please
great thank you very much yeah i agree
so we now move on to item agenda number
nine
capital and investment strategies for
2122
and the minimum revenue statement 2122
found on pages 195-222
mr leslie could you please present this
report okay so there is a requirement
for the council to have these strategies
and have them approved
annually again uh the capital strategy
shows that no
borrowing is required and expenditure
will be met from the grants
and the capital reserve uh the minimum
revenue provision statement
appendix 4 does show debt uh however i
will point out that this is actually in
relation to
vehicle lease commitments which are
funded from revenue
rather than a need to borrow how they're
accounted for
essentially the capital bids here are
appendix
two uh they have been through the
finance working group
uh they have been kept to a minimum this
year in light of the pandemic
but obviously you need to include items
such as health and safety
obligations their details of each of
those bids are contained
in the appendix which gives more detail
around
each of the projects
okay thank you mr leslie
so the recommendations are set out in
the report are as follows
the committee considers and reviews this
report and the attached appendices and
recommends them for approval
by the council so to the council
little uh to the cat that capital
strategy appendix 1 be approved
that the capital projects bid appendix 2
be approved
that the investment strategy appendix
three be approved
that the minimum revenue provision
statement be approved
if any member wishes to second that
motion please unmute your microphone
and state your name okay second
thank you council
and again uh before we invite anybody to
speak i would like to thank the finance
working group in terms of the work we
put in in terms of getting these things
as it says in the report we have tried
to take a prudent and cautious
approach to this expenditure and to
ensure that
the focus is is what we can afford until
we understand further
implications later this year so the idea
is hopefully
that we come back to some of the capital
bids and review them once we
we move further into the year uh
would any mean other member like to
speak on this
item
counselor channel thank you
chairman um i'm going to appendix 2
um parks vehicle rolling and replacement
program
56 and um it says these are essential
um i was just wondering could this be
something that could be spread over a
two-year period
um i think last year there were seven
items of replacement for the park
so do we look at things
for a rolling program of when we replace
items so last year i think there was
some i think that included a
a mower and this year we've got the
vehicles and can i then just ask how
many
perhaps proposed capital projects did
come forward
because i'm assuming these are the ones
that have been
seen to be the ones that as you gave me
your interactions those that should
progress so
um really just to know where they were
vetted if you like
and where decisions were made or which
should come before the committee
um because it might have been helpful to
see the whole lot and i do note also
from the document
itself the capital uh document that's
before us
it does say that full details of the
proposed capital bids
for 2021 22 including project appraisals
undertaken were presented to council for
approval on the 23rd of feb
so i'm just wondering would it not be
helpful to have all of that here tonight
and also perhaps um just chairman i
think for a number of items on the
agenda
uh the finance and working group minutes
it might have been helpful
because obviously the finance working
group it seems is reporting back but
the reporting back is all encapsulated
um within these documents it's not
um clear maybe what discussions took
place within that working group for
everyone to see how
perhaps certain things have been arrived
at so if that's the point
okay thank you thank you so if we go
back to the committee meeting
in november the four capital uh project
bids was put forward
and at that time if you if you go back
to that agenda there was a big
uh detail in terms of those capital
project bids
in terms of what we've done and in terms
of what the officers have done we
focused on the essential items
and the things that are considered
perhaps not as essential at this moment
in time
have been been reviewed um and
i've just been notified that working
group information is available to all
members
um i'm sure mr leslie can provide that
if you haven't been able to access it
so we have gone through a process all
the capital expenditure bids were did
come to this committee
back in november so it has already been
presented to this committee
i'm talking about council chairman it
does say that everything will go to
council on the 23rd because not all the
memberships part of this committee
mr leslie did you want to come back
you just popped up again thank you yeah
i'm happy to clarify
that statement um i appreciate the
wording
um there is probably rather misleading
in that sense
um what we have in documentation is uh
that which is in the appendices
so that is the documentation which will
come through to council by except that
that
is rather misleading that it does say
cancel um when it's already provided
with this document so that there's no
further
information yeah that's right so it is
only these items that are going towards
council and the other ones that we
we put on hold yeah we'll we will come
back to
at a later stage councillor white
um thank you mr chairman um no i'm not
sure this is 100 relevant but at the
it just dropped my memory at the finance
and working group i actually asked for a
report to be done
where we costed out the benefits of um
buying machinery and providing labor
as opposed to using contractors because
in my experience contractors are always
more effective
they've got a yeah slightly more um
i don't know that they're they're
they're keen to get work done very
quickly because it's in their interests
because they'll probably get paid per
job
rather than just a wade and i did ask
the report to come forward
where we could compare the costings and
because i was worried about wage creep
and buying machinery
we could outsource it cheaper um and i
don't unless i'm
mistaken i haven't actually seen it so i
wonder if
one i'm blind and can't see or two
whether it was done
so that work hasn't yet been done
because yeah that would be
a separate piece of work to the capital
projects which is which is what we're
looking at
uh in terms of that and in terms of the
strategy in terms of the
the resulting the parts department yeah
there is a whole
uh piece of work that that could be done
there and in terms of i'll say
uh in terms of a revenue thing what uh i
i
yeah apart one mr butcher
is that we are looking for the
opportunities to
use that and to use the parts department
as a revenue earner
so obviously when that that moves
forward
it is a separate item to this particular
agenda so this moment
in time that is not what we're
discussing counselor durham
yeah thank you very much indeed i mean
this is let's be honest this is the
smallest capitalist
that i've seen in 10 years so and for
obvious reasons and
and and i do support the uh the
the um this item i'm just looking at the
um
the new birthing at burnham when this
helix finally
finally goes uh and that's something
that we've been working on for a long
time
120 000 pounds is quite a lot um
that's uh showing um an annual income of
of 24 000 pounds which when you look at
it
against what we've just been discussing
seems like an awful lot i'm just
wondering what the roi
is um on that um
[Music]
it's uh as i said 120 000 pounds um
is a great deal of money if it is going
to produce a positive um
a positive income for the authority then
it should be
looked at but it looks like quite a long
term payoff
from what i remember and in terms of the
cost benefit analysis it was presented
by mr butcher
it should pay off within five years so
we should get
we should start the pay off that that
expenditure within five years
okay yeah that's fine counselor
yeah thank you chair um to agree with
councillor durham the the list of
the capital projects is incredibly small
and i just want to acknowledge and
appreciate
uh the working group um yourself chair
and especially the officers because the
list was
rather large and the due diligence and
scrutiny that went into to looking at
the sort of essential
spins um has resulted in and these these
works
being proposed now um so i think that
there has been an awful lot of work done
uh behind the scenes to get to a level
where it is essential
and would be beneficial to the district
so i just want to acknowledge and
appreciate mr leslie and the team
so thank you thank you council and
council channel you need you want to
come back could you be
succinct please
yes thank you chairman it was just the
issue of the two vehicles and um
obviously i appreciate what you said
about um the previous meeting and now mr
leslie's confirmed that um
perhaps the wording was misleading um in
the report
the 56 000 are there going to be two new
vehicles
and my question really was obviously it
says essential so i'm assuming they're
both required in this current
current year they they are uh
and it was it was due to the the point
where the the current vehicles are
likely to break down but
i can go to mr butcher uh if he wants to
answer that in any more detail
yes thank you chair yes i i just to
reiterate what you've said the they are
essential items only we really have um
whittled it down and
uh so much so that we'll be running some
of the vehicles at risk this year
um that they may break down and you know
if we need to then we'll come back to
council and committee
for further capital investment in the
course of the year um
but but we we work closely in the
working group to try and really reduce
the
capital money uh being spent this year's
but but what you see there
is the essential items only okay thank
you mr butcher
so uh what i'd like to do is uh can we
agree
those recommendations via us by ascent
great great okay agreed
revised 20 20 21 estimates
original 21 22 budget estimates
and council tax 2122 found on pages
22 2200 to 250 lots of 20s there
in her moment i'd like to call mr leslie
to present that report there's a good
tongue twister
okay so as previously reported to the
committee
in the past kogit has had a significant
impact on
the council finances and it's estimated
that this will cause a
700 000 pound overspend uh
at the end of the year i think it's
reflected in the previous reports as
well
uh the largest impact is coming from the
loss of car parking income
and payments to the leisure provider i
think
that we're aware of the proposed budget
for next year
is currently showing a small service of
31 000
with the council having benefited from
another year of the new homes bonus that
was announced in the provisional
settlement there is a proposed five
pounds increase in council tax
in the budget taking the average that's
the ban d amount
to 207 pounds 40 pence
this would generate additional 125
000 pounds which over a four year period
is an additional half a million pounds
there remains significant risk from the
pandemic to successfully achieving
the proposed budget and table 3
at paragraph 3.18.5
does outline some high risk areas
and their significant financial impacts
appendix two and three of the report
provides budgets at a detailed level um
however we've got the medium-term
financial strategy
report up next which provides more of a
sunrise
position and i'll talk through that
report
next as well my statement
where i give assurance on the robustness
of the budget and adequacy of reserves
is at appendix 5
and the minimum level of reserve of 2.6
million remains unchanged and is
forecast to be
above this by the end of next year
thank you mr leslie so the
recommendations are set out in the
report
are as follows little warned that the
committee notes the main details of the
provisional
local government finance settlement 2122
described in sections 3.4 of this report
to the council little two that the
following be approved
a the revised 21 12 sorry 2020 one
an original 20 122 general fund revenue
budget estimates
appetites one two and three b
an average band d council tax of 207
pounds 40 pence
excluding parish precepts which is a
five pound increase
for 21 22 appendix 1
policies on the designated use of
financial reserves
appendix 4 maintain the current policy
of a minimum general fund balance
of two million six hundred thousands if
any member wishes to
second that emotion please unmute your
microphone
and state your name second
thank you very much councillor swain
uh would any item now wish to make
a comment on the reports
i'll take that as a cent then okay
uh so oh counselor chairman so sorry
did you miss out recommendation little
three mr chairman
or was i did i just turn a deaf ear it
might not be
on my my uh
guide so hold on a minute where are we i
could be wrong chair
um we're on number 10 aren't we
there isn't so yes little three is not
on my uh
on my uh chairman prompt it's a little
three i'll say
that the council gives due regard to the
director of resources
section one five one officer statement
on the robotness
robustness of the budgets and adequacy
of the revert reserves in appendix
five so again could i have a second for
that as well please
yeah yeah thank you very much councillor
durham
council channel
um thank you very much um chairman
obviously for the budget um
there's the three main streams of income
isn't there um
fees and charges grants council tax
um could i just have confirmation
because i'm i'm thinking back to the
briefing now
and i'm very well aware of um the moneys
to help us from the government to help
with kovid
19. and um i i'm
recollect we've set up a contingency
fund i think that was two elements it
was um there's a lower tier services
grant i believe and also the kovid 19
funding
but um i seem to re recollect um
kobe specific fanny are there any
outstanding things that we still need to
be notified of at this current time
because obviously the budget um when on
the 23rd of february
more detail we'll have the precept of
parish councils and i know they're not
included in the
budget as such like that but also what
the police and crime commissioner might
be um
advocating but is there any unknowns and
i think there might be because there's
the pooling arrangements that we have
i'm not quite clear that all the figures
we're totally aware of now they may or
may not have an influence
on the budgetary um calculations
um but the five pound is a 2.4
um seven increase i think which is i
think we're using 0.7
as the inflation rate as well so um
it seems the budget's coming forward
with the options put forward either two
percent or five percent which is
obviously the larger and therefore
obviously it's seen we're going for the
larger element which is the five pounds
so there's a couple of questions they
can
perhaps through youtube mr leslie
advised uh what other information
might be coming through um
before we get to the 23rd of february
when hopefully
all certainties will be known so we are
going for the the largest increase that
we can do without a referendum which is
the five pounds
as far as i'm aware there are no other
grants
or monies coming from government at this
moment in time so i believe that mr
leslie has presented
what our budgets will be for the
following year
so there is no additional funding what
liz leslie is presenting to us tonight
is what the funding is for 2122
at this moment in time
so obviously there will be the the
precepts that essex county council set
and that but that is all separate and
this is yeah to
the budget that we're setting ourselves
this evening and that will be going to
full council
mr leslie
yeah thank you chair um just to pick up
on
um a couple of the points um i think in
terms of
uh the pooling was mentioned um to that
side
now the pooling um is based on actuals
so we only know uh when we get to the
end of the year
what the actual pauline results are and
when we close the accounts
so we have to go on estimates and we use
essex county
council coordinates that so uh for this
year we won't know the actuals obviously
until the accounts are closed
and the same for next year um until we
actually get to the end of next year
we're not going to know what the um the
actual pollings is so we use estimates
currently from from essex county uh
council i think that's in regards to
three point five point
three or one of the reports which uh
which i've just had to look at so i
understand what's been asked um after
reading that
uh there is a i can't remember it's in
the reports of my head but there is uh
15 million pounds the government have
announced to be
allocated uh in respect of
uh audit uh fees um across
the country now we don't know what the
allocation will be uh at this stage it
could be a very small allocation for us
given the size
of the authority uh from that
but there are also some additional costs
in relation to that but
it's also hard to predict so this stage
we don't know
uh around around that side so i just
wanted to provide a bit more
clarity um around that and
i think the kovid grant i don't think
there was a question on that i think
that was
uh i think that was a statement so yeah
thank you chair just wanted to provide
counseling do you want to
uh you still got your hands up as well
mr leslie's on
do you have any further questions yes
please yes mr leslie
mentioned the 15 million um and um yes
that is coming forward because the
redmond as we know
has uh affected um the audit and we know
um indeed it was
through the briefing process mr leslie
did highlight what that is shown i think
a number of us were quite
concerned about actually and i know the
leader was
but i have read the 15 million in
generic's comments i got the impression
reading it chairman that in fact um
the 15 minute i got a there'd be
significant coverage so
i feel that's a use useful bit of um
knowledge we need to have and i'm hoping
that comes forward soon because i
i thought they were going to let us know
relatively soon but also i'm aware from
pga that there was going to be a meeting
also with the auditors
i believe the chairman and vice chairman
were having that because there was going
to be a discussion
um regarding what we're referring to now
so i would like to perhaps be aware of
any outcomes of that i'm sure we all
might be interested because um
at pga mr leslie you made a statement um
beforehand but also um at a meeting i
was at with
the lead on getting which one it was now
but a number of us were
couldn't recall actually the essence of
that well a doubling really that's what
we're talking about that is what we were
talking about so i think that's quite
significant have all the information
surrounding that in our budget processes
and hopefully that will be before you
know we get that by the 23rd of february
obviously we don't have any control of
it that coming forward do we mr leslie
uh no no we we don't and i think it's
appreciated that
some budgets obviously uh may be better
some budgets may
be worse and i think that's part of the
estimate one of the things that
that i yeah that's very good with mr
leslie and and and the way that he does
uh do uh finances and that is he is he
is very cautious in terms of things so
he does tend to go for the worst case
scenario so hopefully
things said which is i think in the in
the current situation is is the right
approach for a financial officer and
i commend him for that uh councillor
stilts
uh thank you mr chair just to uh
assure councillor chana um
we actually haven't had the meeting on
that
audit report yet on that budget but as
soon as we do
that we'll come back to pgna so just to
assure her that we are still
on the case for that thank you
councillor stilts so i'd like to now
move
on to the vote can i agree
these uh reports via ascent
agreed great agreed
okay thank you very much so now
chairman i will i will reserve judgement
until i see all the um budget papers and
hopefully some of this information
council stilts has given we might know
that as well if the meeting is held
before the but
so if you do not give us the sent we
have to go to a recorded vote
do you want to record a vote counselor
channel um
i don't think it has to be recorded but
i think it does have to if there is not
full ascent
there has to be a recorded vote so
councillor tanner are you asking for a
recorded
i should put my caveat on that then that
um i will
support but it will be dependent on some
of this information coming forward and
council still might be having that
meeting which might be helpful actually
okay so we are we are now taking this by
ascent can i have a cent please
agreed thank you
agreed thank you very much so we now
move to
our agenda item 11 the medium term
financial strategy
for 2021 to 22
to 22 23 24
found on pages 251 to 296.
mr leslie could you please present the
report
okay so in the report table one there at
paragraph 4.1 i think on page
252. mine is correct uh that gives quite
a nice
uh summary of the annual changes that
take place
to the budget it's a good overview of
the budget
set in there of course there's more
detail
around some of those key items such as
the growth items they have been through
the
finance working group uh and reduced as
well the minimum levels
uh around health and safety and sensible
investment
there and they're summarized at table
two
in the report and that also shows
the funding from the reserves made in
regards to the local development plan
and local development scheme there
which is being met from the new homes
bonus and a transformation
reserve
further information as well at appendix
2
in terms of the details of those growth
items is provided
repairs and renewals are appendix 3.
um again they've been reviewed by the uh
finance working group uh just pressures
i'll point to as well because pressures
make up a part of that and
the details around that are in the mtfs
on page 280 appendix a
i will highlight a large figure within
there which relates to the pension
deficit contribution
we paid 1.6 million this year
as part of the triannual review of
course that's going to be removed
from the budget for next year however we
are going to
contribute 520 000 pounds
a year to the pension deficit reserve
so for the next triangle review we have
sufficient funding
um to cover to cover that
uh the covered impact is largely
uncertain to predict
um and i've previously mentioned we've
got a
contingency of 371 000
in next year's budget for this
and that's been made possible by the
additional government grants
that we've had the kowid grant
um that's coming in particular to
support that
um however of course we said before that
there's a risk that this won't be enough
and um table three in this report the
same was the prettiest one really
highlights
those those key risks and the challenge
we're up against
uh there just lastly i would point to
chart one
um there in the body of the report
paragraph four point
two which shows an increase in budget
gap due to declining funding
in 2223 and of course inflationary
pressures there
based on a do-nothing scenario with the
general fund balance dropping below the
minimum level of 2.6 million
by 23.24 obviously action will be taken
to try and address this
and the new homes bonus consultation is
expected um
soon about the future of new homes bonus
going forward into 22 23 and beyond
and that could possibly improve the
funding position
but at the moment we just don't have
that information
thank you chair thank you mr leslie so
the recommendation has sat out in the
report is as follows
to the council that the updated medium
term financial strategy
or 2021 22
to 20 23 24 as at
the 28th of january 2021
at appendix one be remember recommended
to council
if any member wishes to second that
motion please unmute and state your name
seconded oh oh i'll go with councillor
stamp for a change
well i had trouble with the technology
last time
thank you thank you both
are there any uh members who wish to
speak on this
before we move to the vote i think
council tony you still have your hand up
from the previous item unless you want
to speak on this one
no okay uh
so can we take the report and the vote
virus sent please
agree right thank you very much
thank you very much so we now move to
agenda item 12 annual review of
financial regulations
found on pages 297-356
and surprise surprise i'm going to call
on mr leslie to uh present the report
apologies chip um this is the
annual review of the financial
regulations which is quite keep it up to
date
the appendices you can see the changes
that are being made i mean this year it
is just a case of making sure it aligns
the current structures
as well so there's actually no um
significant change around the financial
regulations it's mainly ensuring that it
accords with their current strategy
rather than pointing to posts which are
redundant or things that no longer exist
so it's basically an update to refresh
our current working
arrangements thank you mr leslie so the
recommendations this out of the report
is as follows
recommendations to the council that the
revised financial regulations
attached at appendix one be approved if
any member wishes to second that motion
please unmute and state your name second
case of lagging
whoa cancel
who would like to speak on this report
okay can i take uh that via sent them
please
great great good agreed thank you very
much members
so we moved to agenda item 13 contract
procedure rules review and update
found on pages 357
to 394 and i call on mr leslie to
present the report
okay so again a review that needs to
take place but
for some more substantial changes
proposed uh in this one and they're
outlined in
section three of the report and of
course there's the
track changes as well so you can see
that the appendices
i will highlight here that um previously
um
the tender value uh threshold was
actually reduced from fifty thousand to
twenty five
thousand uh in the past uh as a result
of a um
of a change uh however there was
actually no um
legal requirement or otherwise to reduce
the threshold down to that 25
000 um so the proposal is actually to
put it back uh up to 50 000
to where it used to be uh the reason for
that
is one it's operationally um
easier to actually uh go and we also
have
it says there in the report actually the
auditors actually commented
on the low threshold which does make it
operationally uh difficult
uh at times the other reason is that the
uh
reset and recovery working group uh
looking at how we could
assist local businesses uh one of the
things that we can do
is actually look at how we have barriers
for them to access council work
and one of the ways is to make sure that
they have equal access
um where you can look at businesses who
may be
very good at their trade but perhaps
aren't as
experienced in terms of bid writing and
actually winning
and those bids surprise us some
flexibility to support their
local businesses which came out of the
reset and recovery
working group i think it'd be remiss of
me as well if i didn't highlight
that within there it's a request that
the director of resources
has the discretion to agree other
methods of disposals
of council assets up to a value of five
thousand pounds
in consultation with uh relevant
directors uh that's being added there
because
uh we can have quite uh low value uh
disposals um which does make
it difficult at times to dispose of it
should we say efficiently because of the
current requirements
uh in place but obviously we would still
be seeking uh
best value for money in that thank you
ms leslie so before i go to the
recommendation like mr leslie
i would like to thank the kovid 19 reset
and recovery group for all the work that
they've done
and for the work that they've done in
terms of bringing these forward
these items to this committee and
there's been some excellent work
on that particular working group so i'd
like to
thank them for that so the
recommendation are set out in the report
as as follows
and that is to the council that little
one that the revised contract procedure
rules at appendix one are approved
that the director of resources is
authorized to make minor changes to the
contract procedure rules
minor changes are defined as changes in
statutory framework
such as references to new or updated
legislation
changes in titles names or terminology
changes consequential to other
constitutional changes
already made if anyone wishes to second
that motion please unmute your
microphone
and state your name second councillor
swain
thank you councillor swing
so now i'd like to invite members to
speak on this item
and the first person is councillor
durham yeah thank you chairman
and and i think i i welcome any
uh initiative to you know put business
to
local businesses uh and if they're not
directly local then certainly to essex
businesses
uh and i think that's really good just a
quick question i take it that oju went
out the window with the rest of
uh the eu paraphernalia um
because we we have we did have i believe
it or not
so uh things like the leisure contract
and the waste
conf we to go through the og procedure
which was
um let's just call it um a pain in the
neck but i'm assuming that
i'd thought so uh counselor channel
could i just answer that yeah yeah
um it's no longer called oju
it doesn't actually have a name so we're
just calling it over threshold
but those thresholds still apply there
is a consultation
for transforming public procurement and
there's a green paper and that
should close in march um
so in a month or so couple of months and
but the government are looking at
simplifying the whole process it was
just they
stopped dead on 31st of december
and it's all a bit up in the air at the
moment but
it is working towards making it a much
simpler process
i should add that the oju and any
process
at modern has been extremely complicated
and we've worked quite hard to try and
pull that back and simplify it right
across the board
okay come up with supplementary
supplements
so um so just to clarify so we're not
having to offer our contracts to
european businesses then
which is the case under ig no what's
happened now where
we would have to publish a contract
advert that was over certain thresholds
via oj the european um portals
um the government of nan got their own
one called find a tender
um and it will be published across there
but there will be nothing going out by
uh european portals
okay thank you thank you thank you mr
councillor channel
thank you
uh thank you chairman um i'm just trying
to
get the document up here because it's
easier than trying to go between my
screen and the document on the screen
um just to say i do welcome this report
actually because i think it does assist
um small businesses which of course this
council is always keen to do offer the
business community support
um just read about the process of it
because it
it did go to the covid 19 reset and
recovery group
um which was set up by council but i
noticed it's come
to this committee so i'm just interested
in
in the travel of it really because um
the kovid 19 um
reset and recovery didn't report back to
council i don't think on this so i was
expecting
from what i can recall in actually the
notes of that meeting
i think um there was a presentation at
that working group and it said it would
go
um to council in january or february
but it seems that this there's a layer
coming it's arrived at um statutory
resources
so effectively now um the it won't be
going to the
fourth of feb because i can't see the
timelines will allow that from
what i'm looking at on here my mobile
and therefore it'd be
march i'm assuming this document will go
forward so there's a bit of delay in it
so i just wondering
um why perhaps it came to statutory
resources when i
thought the documents going straight up
to full council as a policy document of
this
of the authority um to get approval on
um
the fourth of feb um full council
mr leslie yeah thank you
yeah that was uh i think the original
intention but uh
what that probably process didn't
probably appreciate is actually uh
the contract procedurals should go to
snr committee beforehand
and then recommend it on to council for
that and that's actually the correct
process
um to do that so it's going to take a
bit longer but that's the process it
follows
thank you mr leslie for that
clarification councillor white
um thank you mr chairman um i mean i
haven't seen the
body of this document but are we setting
forward a process where we can encourage
our local businesses to tender
um because i haven't seen that in there
again and it might be that i just
haven't seen it in there because this is
important now we don't have to go
through europe i think that we should
make um
particular remembrance that we we put
local businesses to the fore
and to try and allow them to see these
um contracts come up because i know a
lot of
um local companies don't know how to
apply
for these contracts they might well be
able to fulfill them
and i think um particularly following on
from kovid that we need to actually
support the businesses and
encourage them to apply for the tenders
so if we can i'd like something
put in to um help that to be done
so i i i believe that's the intention of
this uh
new procedures but uh mrs white if you'd
like to clarify for us
yeah i'd like to make sure that it's
actually written into the contract and
it's to this
counselor white i was calling on mrs
debbie white ah sorry yeah
that's okay we can't actually
do that at the moment um a procurement
policy note was released by the cabinet
office a little while ago that i
circulated to the directors
um which put quite a big emphasis on um
smas local businesses etc and how to
reserve
by area so we from that procurement
policy note we would have been able to
say
we only want to businesses from malden
for example to bid for this work there's
been a lot of legal review on that
so at the moment that's just under
discussion
and so we've got to be really careful
how we move forward
in terms of encouraging local businesses
we do not have a
procurement website and this is
something that i said back in their
working group
that we actually need something on our
website something simple
something that people can see and some
contact details so that they can come to
us
and get the right information quickly
and
this will be follow as of the approval
for these contract procedurals i did not
want to put something
up that was we was waiting to change
um i just wanted it to remain consistent
and say this is what we do
and once we have the procedurals in
place then we can move it forward and
and set up portals on our website
to encourage local businesses to exactly
brilliant yes
so i know i know that some of our
businesses they wouldn't do work for the
council but we're on a lot of national
um lists but a lot of local businesses
don't even know how you get onto them
um and take it forward but i mean i
wouldn't want it just for mouldings i
still want it to be competitive but
that's brilliant the work you're doing
sounds fantastic
it's going to have to be project
specific and then a view can be taken
through the
project group and the working groups
that we've passed
thank you councillor councillor thank
you mrs white thank you
so uh we now move to the vote can we
agree this report via a sent please
agree agree very much
thank you so we now move to
item number 14 the generation 14 which
is the council
tax support scheme 2122 found
pages 395 to 406 and this time i'm going
to call on mrs green
to present this report
good evening members um hopefully this
is a fairly straightforward report for
you this evening
um as part of our process for setting
the council tax support scheme
which is the help we give to our
residents on low income to pay the
council tax we are required by
legislation to set the scheme
each year we can't have a rolling scheme
um
what's before you tonight is a proposal
um to
keep the scheme substantially unchanged
there's a few minor
changes which are to ensure that the
scheme
does stay consistent with the national
scheme in respect of pensioners
and more specifically there is a
provision this year
to ensure that mid-year if there are any
changes that are announced as a result
in particular of covid
that the scheme can be changed mid-year
if required
and what we saw last year is some
changes to
provide some additional income for
people on universal credit
and because we had already set the
scheme and they made no provision to
amend it
and there was a an issue in that the
customers that received that additional
income
could have been disadvantaged so to
ensure that doesn't happen this year we
have made sure that there is provision
within the scheme
to deal with any under unintended
consequences
of any welfare changes that are
introduced to assist customers in the
year
apart from that members i think the
scheme as i say remains substantially
unchanged
and we put it before you this evening we
have undertaken equality impact
assessment
and to ensure that there is no adverse
impact
and a copy of that has been attached to
the report members
and i'm very happy to take any questions
thank you mr screen
so i'd like to now move to the
recommendation and the recommendation
that's set out in the report is as
follows
which is to the council the little one
that the following changes to the
existing local con
council tax support scheme ltc
lcts are approved cost of living
increase in line with the department for
work and pension schemes
be included in the local council tax
support scheme
for 20 21 22 for pensioners only
b that any legitimate changes being
introduced to the housing benefit scheme
for 21 22 are mirrored in the council's
lcts scheme to ensure consistency
that amendments to the discretionary
provisions of the lcts
to ensure that the council is able to
administer the various schemes to
reflect
local and national guidance d that the
lcts
may reflect any additional changes to
government welfare benefit regulations
during the year which are intended to
increase the income of benefits
recipients and be introduced introduced
during a financial year 2
to avoid any intended consequences to
customers
e that this decision has been made
following members careful reading of
and regard to the equality impact
assessment at appendix 1.
if any member wishes to second admission
please don't mute your mind
thank you very much council helm uh i
know invite
uh uh
i now invite members to uh ask any
questions on this report
or take that that they don't mrs green
uh i'd just like to say thank you very
much for your hard work and also the
hard work that your
your team has been doing over the the
covered
situation and you're doing sterling work
thank you chairman thank you members
okay
uh so can we take this report via ascent
agreed great
okay thank you very much
so we now move to agenda item 15
pay policy statement found on pages 407
to 414 and i'll call on mrs cardy
to present this report
thank you chair um so to present the
report the pay policy statement
is an annual statutory requirement which
describes the approach of the authority
on pay related matters
particularly the remuneration of the
highest and lowest paid staff
it has to be annually approved at
council and published on our website by
the first of april
there are specific requirements that
must be included and one of which is the
pay
multiple which is the ratio between the
highest paid earner in
our case the directors and the average
earnings for the whole workforce
in malden the highest paid is 3.7 times
the average earnings
the government maximum for this is 20
times the average so we
fall well below this the policy also
sets out
and the mdc are committed to paying the
real
living wage to our lowest paid staff and
details the annual percentage pay
increase
which is a nationally agreed increase
the committee are asked to agree this
statement ahead of
approval that council next week and then
publish
publication on our website in line with
the statutory requirements
happy to answer any questions thank you
mr cardi
so the recommendations i set out in the
report is as follows
to the council that the pay policy
statement attached at appendix 1
to this report be adopted for 2021.
if any man wishes to second that motion
please unmute and state your name
council hell my second that thank you
very much councillor helm
uh do we have any questions for mrs
cardy
on this particular item we'll take that
as a name mrs cardy
thank you thank you very much for your
time thank you
uh so i would now like to put the
uh report to a cent can i have a sent
from members
please thank you very much members
so we now move on to agenda item 16
which is the insurance tender found on
pages 415
to 420 in a moment i will call on
mr morrell to present this report
good evening chairman and members it's
almorell of resources casework manager
i'm the project lead for this report and
thank you to debbie white for
assistance in preparing it uh we're
working with a
external broker to provide a solution
for insurance requirements and we need
to be compliant by the first of october
of 2021 this is to ensure that we're
protected against major losses and limit
our financial exposure but also to
comply with our statutory requirements
there's a table in 3.4 which outlines
the options that we're required to be
tended at an estimated total cost over
the period of one million pounds
um our proposal is for a solution which
meets our needs for five years with an
option to extend for a further two if if
we need to
we've already formed a project uh
management group which
is already met to start to deliver our
requirements along with a project plan
to make sure that we can ensure that to
obtain the best rates and that
appropriate cover
is secured by the deadline of the 1st of
october
this is an outline of our recommendation
but again um more than happy to answer
any further questions
if required thank you thank you mr
morrell
so the recommendations are set out in
the report are as follows
to the council that little one that the
tender process to ensure the council has
compliant insurance contracts
in place by the first of october 2021 be
commenced
that little two that the insurance
contract tend to process to be put in
place
for five years with an option to extend
the process
for a further two years long-term
agreement
could anybody who wish to second that
motion
unmute to your microphone and state your
name now please
second council swain thank you
councillor swain
if any member would like to speak so
councillor channel you've raised your
hand
um thank you chairman i've just noticed
it actually um
italian's just come back in my memory
sales um
gallagher um the broker or whatever um
i'm actually well perhaps uh family
family's dealing with something with
them at the moment so
perhaps on this one i just keep out the
equation
actually that's just come to me
something all right thank you councillor
china councillor swain
um yes i'm just interested perhaps mr
morale could um
uh just give a brief idea what are the
major
um elements of that million pound
insurance in other words what's really
costing us the most in insurance
okay if i can call on uh my colleague
debbie
white to potentially answer that
question for me
this is right
yeah they it's it's the different cost
of all the different policies that
you'll see all the different lots that
are listed in that report um
offhand i can't remember the actual
individual prices for each lot
and is this something that if mr if
councillor swain requires you can send
to him after the communication
yes that's fair enough okay
yes okay thank you mr morale thank you
mrs white
so again can we agree this report via
ascent
agreed oh councillor fleming you've just
raised your hand
too late too late i'm afraid oh
i'm i'm not commenting i said on this no
but council foaming so
cancer was was it any would you like to
ask your question we have we have now
agreed it why i said but was there a
particular
i would thank you um i was just
interested on the why the five years
is it um obviously we have to go to
tender and employ a broker to do that
there's a cost involved so so do you set
the price
an annual sort of price for for the five
year period plus
another two is it set and the reason for
the five years i was interested to know
okay um we we've
calculated the price based on this
year's premiums for insurance which is
the hundred and forty four thousand
two seventy and when you go to tender
you have to have the lifetime value
of the contract so irrespective of
whether we're going to take up the
two-year option
so in essence the million pounds is for
seven years worth of
insurance so that's kind of an estimate
what we've also done is the time and
resource to carry out
an insurance tender is immense this is a
year-long project
or you know we've sort of been looking
at this collating
information for quite a while now
generally i would say that most tenders
i try to keep at
sort of three three plus two sort of
terms
in the case of insurance once these uh
insurance companies are awarded the
contract
first off for that length of contract
that's not unusual for insurance that's
about normal
and secondly we'll get a greater price
at the off
offered through the tender process and
then
with the insurance we have to go back
out every year
to get prices for renewals
so because we are contacting them it's
not that just it's a static price
we did make some savings this year um
very minimal but this has now been
picked up and looked at and
because of the amount of work that we're
doing from a sort of
a new perspective we're hoping that
we can bring the premiums down as of
this year so
um that's what we're looking for so
we're hoping
that's worst case scenario christ but we
did need to take this year's
um values great thank you
thank you mr spike thank you mr murray
so we have agreed already via sent so i
will move on from that a tender item
uh so we move on to agenda item 17 which
is the corporate plan
update 21 20 to 23
found on pages 421-426
uh mr dodson would you like to present
the report
yes thank you chairman um as set out in
the committee report
it's recommended that a task and finish
working group be established by this
committee to review and validate the
corporate plan
update against the feedback received
from the member engagement survey
the members will be aware this survey
held between the 4th and 18th of january
2021
sought views on the existing corporate
plan whether there were any particular
areas of the council's work
focus that members felt council
resources could be better deployed to
and for the first time
which common values should be adopted
for the organization
once established this working group
would distill the feedback received and
consider this against proposed outcomes
of the updated corporate plan
prior to its consideration by council
for you council swain could you please
switch off your microphone
councillor swain could you please switch
off your microphone
thank you sorry mr dodson would you like
to continue
okay um yes basically the the working
group
um would distill the feedback received
and consider this against proposed
outcomes of the updated corporate plan
prior to its consideration by council
for adoption in march
2021 thank you thank you very much mr
dozen
so the recommendations are that the
progress made on developing the update
to the corporate plan be noted
little two to the corporate plan task
and finish working group
be established to review and validate
that updated corporate plan
prior to its referral to the council in
march 2021
little three that six strategy resources
committee members be appointed to serve
on the corporate plan
task and finish group anybody wishes
member wishes to second that motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name now please
thank you councillor stamp i now
ask members if they wish to speak on
this item counselor channel
um thank you chairman um i'm just
recollecting um
pga committee actually um a little while
back
and um there was considerations
obviously the performance of the
corporate pan
and the thematic um areas
and i do recall and i think i know the
answer this but i'm just a little bit
disappointed
um i guess because obviously it's now
come to snr and i think that was
actually mentioned in the minutes of pga
that it would become up snr
but the working group that's being done
this is a whole council
matter and i just make the point um that
we've had the member
engagement survey done but i do recall
it being said and i think i might know
the reasons for this but there was meant
to be
um or certainly it was reported at um
pga
an all council workshop on the corporate
plan because obviously it is
a whole council matter and it's come to
snr and the working group
is being taken from this committee
whereas previously
regarding corporate plans um there was a
working group i think that was taken
from across the whole council
in terms of the corporate plan and
looking at it because then they had a
balance
from where members might be coming from
so
i think what's happening is the
engagement survey is replacing the
workshop
we've got the um the working group will
now look at
uh what members and other persons might
come forward with and then bring
something back to this committee
and that will recommend to council where
the corporate plan to me
is a holistic thing that whole council
should consider and any working groups
should come across the membership of all
committees
that's just a point i make chairman
thank you councillor china
there is a there is a name in this
in terms of this committee in terms of
it's called strategy so the corporate
plan does connect into strategy
if the working group decides perhaps
that
we do need to have some kind of wider
full council
uh yeah session then obviously that
could be part of what that working group
identifies
um but the in terms of the strategy in
terms of the thematic strategies
they report into the strategy and
resources committee
and that's the way that it is it is um
defined
um am i am i correcting that mr dodson
um clearly this is the strategy and
resources committee
um and it would be appropriate for the
the strategy
development to come to come through this
process i do
um absolutely um note um councillor
chana's
comments and it was the initial um
an in initial direction was that we were
looking to have a
all council working uh workshop
at the start but we did as again as
councillor chandler
noted um replaced that with the survey
um which
which got a good engagement um we had
over
um around 70 of members responded into
that
um by the deadline which was was really
useful and has informed the discussion
which will happen at the
working group should it go ahead thank
you mr dudson
councillor fleming
thank you chair i just want to echo
councillor
uh concerns i feel disenfranchised
so um yeah i personally feel that
um living limiting membership to
strategy and resources committee members
you know possibly limits expertise
across the membership
anyway thank you thank you councillor
fleming
council channel you wanted to come back
um thank you chairman
yes um part of the reasoning as well i
think across the whole council and well
i would have thought a workshop would
have been a very good idea and whether
or not that can still come into the
process although i
recognize it saying got to be reported
back at march a bit timely
um and this is no disrespect at all but
i think we have newer members on the
council
and to be faced with a member engagement
survey
um about a corporate plan they may not
have necessarily had the
involvement in at the time and it you
know it was 2019 i think it largely done
about february 2019
um you know to have a whole member
workshop where they could get a greater
comprehension and understanding
i think would have been a beneficial
thing like we've always done like with
the ldp
and things like that yes there was a
panel from a committee but then it went
forward and there were
briefings and seminars so that's part of
my disappointment really i think to
assist
actually those members that came on in
2019 which may not have been involved in
the process
and would i think have achieved great
benefits from an all member workshop and
most certainly
i do think um the membership should be
spread from across
the council because it is a council
document
i appreciate what you've said about this
is the strategy and
uh committee a resources committee but
yes
strategy doesn't necessarily have to
encampulate without the corporate plan
and as i say normally to my knowledge
most certainly the last corporate plan
was a matter of full council the the
working group came from that and it
reported
um um to full council i i think i'm
correct on that understand to be
corrected if i'm wrong
but i i just make that point and i can
see councillor fleming's point of view
i i can appreciate that point of view
and it is discussion that
that yeah me as chairman of strategy and
resources
has had with with with other uh members
and uh the leader of the council and we
decided at this particular
point in time that it you know because
we want to move this forward
now in terms of the the corporate plan
the court plan is not the one that was
originated in 2019
it has been updated already so we are
moving forward with that corporate plan
it's not the same corporate plan and
from what i understand
there's been far more engagement with
this corporate plan than there was in
2019
so um we are we will if we as a
whoever's in the working group decide
that there needs to be more engagement
with the within the council
as it moves forward then that sort of
thing can be introduced
but at the moment we need to move this
forward
and the idea behind this is we are now
establishing
an update to the corporate plan and as
and around that
we are having the working group to move
it forward councillor lagan
yes thank you chair um i listened
deeply with the debate and and and
whilst i was listening i
uh actually take umbrage at the the the
uh
comments that uh the the skills base of
the newer members may not be sufficient
to actually contribute
to a successful corporate strategy and
you can shake your head all you like but
you could that's what you were saying
i feel that there's a a lot of um skills
base
a lot of knowledge and an awful lot of
good that can come from a fresh approach
looking at a corporate plan to take
a fresh administration into the future
rather than hankering on and putting
your hooks back into the things in the
past
so i fully support this being a
strategic
plan through a strategy and resources
committee
thank you logan councillor white
um thank you mr chairman i mean actually
i mean i i think we need to take this
forward it needs to be
forward thinking but i also think this
should be an all member working group i
mean the corporate plan is really really
important and i think
to just dumb it down to a few members
is sort of unreasonable and unsafe and i
think we have a lot of
old and new members with lots of skills
not just
confined to half a dozen members and i
honestly think we should
make it a wider group i mean with the
online meetings does it really matter
whether it's six members
or 26 members and i think it should be a
far bigger working group
than just this committee and i think
this is really important um for
democracy and for the residents to make
it more open
i don't think we should make it so
inclusive or you know or exclusive
should i say sorry
thank you councillor i'm not sure about
the word dumb uh
councillor stamp
thank you chairman i think you just need
to look at our screens to see how
experienced councillors and
inexperienced councillors are actually
on this committee themselves
snr i think many of you have been around
for a heck of a long time
i'm not i'm not going to get into the
nitty-gritty there's a proposal on the
table
i think we should go the recommendation
that four um
six members are elected or
nominated from this and we take it
forward thank you chair
thank you councillor stamp councillor
durham
thank you chairman i think there might
have been a misunderstanding with
unless i'm very wrong with what
councillor channel said
um i think what she was saying is that
there's a lot of expertise and
skill with members who aren't on snr
there are lots of
new members on pg a that may be you know
equally able to to contribute i
don't think she was saying uh that the
new members
are haven't got the skills i think we've
established that there's a wide range of
skills but the concern was that there
may be very
able people um on other committees
that aren't um so
i think i think you know councilwagon um
just misunderstood that
um i i'm in two minds here um i
i think that uh you know the danger of
of a much bigger and wider committee we
all know what happens with committees
you end up with a camel
um and you know when you've got too many
people
so i i think that that the working group
should consist of
people with the right skills the right
experience
now whether that is just from snr or
whether uh the other members should be
included
it you know that's that's another matter
altogether
but i certainly wouldn't want um 20 odd
people on the committee as i said
because it's too
unwieldy and and you never actually make
any any
decisions thank you thank you councillor
dunham councillor thompson
thank you chairman um i was actually
going to say pretty much what
councilman did i felt very much that
councillor chandler's point was that
there were new members that
haven't been able to take part in one of
these the poor who aren't on this
committee so they won't be able to this
time either
um so i i think the snippiness
remarks goes both ways to be honest
and uh i think it's time it stopped okay
thank you councillor thompson councillor
can't hear anything i don't know if my
my internet's down
or my account
right um yes i've been calling this a
task and finish group
um it's not going to finish it's not
going to come up with the finished
article
um what um it'll include
things like the values and principles
objectives
and perhaps some key policies in in the
end
and this should all could all be um
subjected to
scrutiny uh criticism addition
by other members it um when it comes to
formal consideration um so i it's not
too important that
we have a big committee at this stage or
big working group
it's going to be subject to criticism
eventually anyway
thank you council this way i have no
more
other members uh who wish to speak
so uh oh counselor durham you want to
come
no
is going to be a devil's own job to come
up with a meaningful corporate plan
particularly in such uncertain times you
know there there are so many
factors you know we have lgr still you
know bubbling under there we have all
sorts of things
we still have uh you know the coded
situation
it's very important that you know it's
we we don't write this on a tablet of
stone and have to keep to it it should
be a fluid enough
document that can change with the
changing circumstances
thank you so if we go to the
recommendations
i would like to uh nominate from the
chair in terms of little three and the
mending recommendation that
the six strategy resources committee
members be appointed to serve
from the corporate plan and task finish
group and they will be made up
of four independents and two
conservatives
and the four independents will be
councillor richard siddall
councillor wendy stamp councillor
christopher swain
and councillor kevin lagan so i would
ask the conservatives
to nominate two people from their group
councillor channel oh well i'm happy to
um
nominate um councillors durham and white
okay thank you very much
so i now move to the vote can we take
this fire
uh a cent or do we need a recorded vote
councillor helm you've put your hand up
is that for me chairman
you just put your hand up yes that's
right uh what about democratic allowance
are we cut
out as well now so we are looking at
ensuring that
we focus on the main groups of the
council
those main groups of the council are the
independents
and the conservatives i have put forward
the recommendation
which is for independents and two
conservatives
i would like to put recommendation you
have one democratic alliance please
so we'd have to vote on the first
recommendation which has already been
put forward
if that recommendation fails then we
will take a second recommendation
so thank you very much mr chairman okay
so are we going to need via do this for
our ascent or do we need a recorded vote
um i'll second you chairman make sure
you've got a second
thank you council
are we doing this so can i take this via
a scent
chairman actually i do recall there is
another working group
um where um the uh i propose thing and
the leader
did so it was good and we did allow to
have a seventh member which was from the
democratic alliance
the recommendation the recommendation
has already been put
by myself if that recommendation fails
we will go to a second recommendation so
i take that that we need a recorded vote
so tara could we have a recorded vote
please
um yes chairman of course chairman i are
you wanting to vote on all the
recommendations or just the working
group
for the moment uh
i think all the recommendations together
okay chairman so that's the three
recommendations and that the six members
of the working group be made up of the
four
independents which is cancer siddal
stamps swain and lagan
and the two conservatives which is
council dharma council miss white
correct remember so if you could
indicate fought against rob stain please
want to call your name
starting with council mrs channel please
against because of the democratic
alliance
council durham yeah i'm afraid i vote
against because i think the democratic
alliance should have a
record thank you councillor edwards oh
thank you councillor helm
[Music]
thank you cancer stamp
four thank you councillor mrs stilts
against because this is not democratic
against and no abstentions thank you
very much thank you tara so that is
approved so we now move on to
agenda item 18 donation of laptops for
essex children found on pages
47 to 428 i would like to call on mr
leslie
to represent the report
declare an interest sorry at the
beginning i should have highlighted this
one i'm an essex county councillor it's
a message
anti-council scheme thank you
council help you still have your hand up
and you still have your mic i did say i
still have my hand up
i'd like to thank you very much for
cutting me out thank you
so mr leslie yeah
thank you we've had a number of
approaches
uh from outside bodies and also
counsellors to donate
laptops to help home schooling of
children
also in this digital age and our current
policies would require approval um at
committees yes in our
committee i have to say at the original
time of uh doing this
we we did uh expect to have more uh
laptops to come forward
um as well and i think perhaps the need
for a committee report uh
on this does uh help
the need for the delegation that was
given earlier and uh
the um contract procedure rules um so i
think that's probably a good step
forward saying we don't necessarily need
a report to come to snr for things like
this
in the future should that be approved uh
but ultimately you can see there are
four
uh laptops and four ipads that
potentially uh
we don't need a obsolete surplus um two
requirements due to their their age
uh you can see there that uh the figures
uh in section four four point one
uh there give the financial indications
of that in terms of what we uh
could possibly um have got should we
have
sold the items so all that information
is available
to the members thank you mr leslie so
the recommendation is set out in the
report is as follows
that the council's four remaining
obsolete laptops and four ipads are
donated to essie count essex county
council's
laptop recycling scheme if any member
wishes to second that motion please
unmute and state your name
second counselor thank you council swain
before i go to the debate i would like
to commend the leader
for the initiative that they've taken on
this and for being the driving force
behind this
recommendation so i think that yeah the
the leader
of the council definitely needs a
recognition for
for for raising this initiative and
moving it forward so thank you leader
so the first person uh on the
to speak is councillor durham
counselor durham he seemed to have
frozen so i'll go to councillor stamp
thank you chair oh i was back do you
want me to start
yeah yeah thank you i'm sorry about that
i've got technically you froze
completely yeah well yeah and even with
the wood burner right next to me
thank you very much um with the greatest
respect to councillor stanford
i think this was an essence county
council initiative i'm an essex county
council of you've done that asset last
week given out 3 000
uh chromebooks and laptops to secondary
school children
and they're just in the process now of
supplying ipads to
primary schools um because primary
schools have been predominantly using
them i mean yeah i totally support this
obviously
it's absolutely vital that that children
are helped to home school
i'm just a little bit surprised we only
got four kicking around i mean i would
have thought there were
there were there were lots of them but
if it's only four uh four
is is a you know that's that's fine it's
interesting to note that essex county
council
have commissioned a malden based company
to do the reconditioning so
um it is actually benefiting um modern
businesses
so yeah i i commend it i i
i'm from what i understand there is more
obsolete equipment but it is mostly
desktops rather than laptops and ipads
so we do have a lot of desktop computers
chairman they will take those uh and
and break them down for spares and the
funds that are raised will go to
purchase new chromebooks so
um they will take they'll take
absolutely
everything so maybe there's something we
can explore
with mr leslie after this committee
uh yeah it is an essex county council
initiative but in terms of moving this
forward within malden district council
it is the leader who has driven this so
we do commend the leader for doing it
counselor stamp thank you chairman
everybody
seems to speak before i get a chance at
the moment but yes i
i think members who know me members who
maybe even don't know me very well i
don't steal people's ideas and other
authorities ideas
it was muted quite some time ago but it
has taken
quite a while for me to get this to come
to council
um it is something that i strongly
support and i also would like to put an
amendment to the proposal if at all
possible
and the fact is my amendment would like
to say specifically to molden district
schools not just to go into the essex
county council pot
because we know that's a greater wider
expanse so i would like to
propose that amendment chair if if mr
leslie and the officers it isn't going
to
incur a great deal more hard work for
the officers to administer
thanks to leslie is that possible
um short answers i don't know because
it's an essex county council scheme so i
don't know how
they would allocate um laptops and how
they operate
i think we could probably say um we will
do that if possible could be
an alternative so i can't guarantee it
one way or another because i simply
don't know the scheme
sorry chairman i do know that a large
number have already been provided to
burnham schools
um from from essex it might be difficult
to say that the very
items that we give will go to it
more than malden schools but i'm sure if
you request
that you know if you give for the four
additional help out here
yeah chairman can i come back i have not
spoken a lot thank you
and the reason that i wanted to go to
the district is that um i have been
contacted
by schools as i'm sure other members of
this council have
because there is a need if you've got a
a family
of four children under the age of 15
and the parents are working from home
and they've only got one laptop and one
phone some
some students are working until 10 and
11 o'clock at night to try and do their
school work and their homework
and i know that's the same everywhere
else but i'm the leader of this council
and we need to do what we can to this
district thank you
thank you councillor channel
yes uh thank you uh chairman yeah um
council damage is an essex um
very successful scheme and i'm glad to
see this council's getting on board
because
a number of other councils are um
already
um and i was going to make the point
about malden schools
um as well because i am aware i do think
that's perfectly feasible and i'm sure
the cabinet member
council louise mckinley would actually
be happy to talk about that and make
sure that the
um laptops do come one question i do
have i know we're talking about four
and we're hearing about desktops which
can be utilized as counselor arms
highlighted
would this be a rolling program so um
therefore we've met we've got very
specific here tonight about numbers
are we saying that's just the one off or
is it envisaged this will be a rolling
program because we're going the rolling
things as we know under the capital
program tonight we've just seen
so uh that this will be ongoing and that
therefore
uh whatever may be you know subject to
us not requiring any further will be
go into this scheme which is worthwhile
it is a case i mean there are families i
have some deprived areas in
my division and indeed my ward at malden
and often a family if with a number of
children if especially with home
schooling or other things or other
educational benefits
it can be difficult if they may not have
a computer indeed they may have some out
of date stuff and the whole family is
trying to share
so it's a very very good scheme thank
you
council fleming
thank you chair i was just going to say
that my understanding is that
um leader you can say that you want uh
the la you know the chromebooks laptops
to go to
uh malden district schools that's my
understanding is you can specify
or request okay uh councillor white
thank you mr just say that i absolutely
support them being distributed to needy
families because it's a big expense a
difficult time
and and i'm all for recycling so i think
any time we can recycle these
you know i think it's a fantastic idea
and i absolutely support it 100
i think with the you know procedure
rules that we talked about earlier in
the committee meeting it
in i think it will be yeah directors
will enable this
this will yeah they've got to do this
without it coming to committee
uh so this yeah it can be an ongoing
prayer and it doesn't necessarily need
to come to committee in the future
because of those procedure rules that
we've we've made earlier in the in
the the meeting uh councillor thompson
uh you just said it for me chairman
thank you i was going to say could we
put in the amendment so the directors
can do this yet again
thank you
okay is those previous hands
counselor channel counselor stamp or so
counselor stamp
uh thank you the reason i wanted to
bring it as soon as possible was because
i was aware that we are going to invest
in new equipment
and i felt it was going to be too long
that we could help the students
uh in our district so yeah i've attended
meetings with the essex county
councillors as well
and i'm really proud that this we are
actually doing something now
and i thank members for the support and
mr leslie
who has moved heaven and earth because i
have been battering him
and i know they're very very busy so i i
thank you all that's great
counselor channel if you be successful
just to say chairman
uh could it be um obviously this is
going to agree we're going to make the
specific requirements to say morden
if members are aware of schools in their
area or any families perhaps
um could you know inform officers so
they have an awareness
you know of where the the uh equipment
could be best utilized
just an idea it might you know could be
across the district or it might really
need to go to the areas where it's most
required really but
some of us may have knowledge of the
schools that um you know the areas
that might require them the families or
something and in fact some of the
um bodies that work in the voluntary
bodies will have a good idea because
many of them are also working
um with with the food bank and food
parcel issues and
other things that have a knowledge that
their children and families well-being
hub
would probably have a knowledge of those
families that could actually benefit
totally from this sort of um scheme
thank you councillor so i'd like to go
back to the recommendation then
and try and incorporate uh what some of
the things we talked about
and that is that they said that the
council's four remaining opposite
laptops and four ipads are donated to
essex county council's laptop recycling
and the the same number of equipment is
donated to
schools in the malden district
can i have a seconder for that please
[Music]
can you state your name counselor
you've come back again
cancer thompson oh sorry um i was only
going to say well i absolutely agree
with that amendment i'd i'd hate to
think to fail
and have to come back to committee
because that couldn't be done
so could we amend the amendment to have
that proviso that
that's the ideal situation which i
absolutely support
but if it can't be done then we'll just
go ahead anyway rather than drag it back
yeah this should be done as soon as we
can it's
you know too many people have managed
too long without the right equipment
again
i think that uh yeah with the changes in
procedure then the directors will be
able to make those decisions without
coming to committee
so i think i think we can take that as
read so can we take that
uh via a cent or do we need to record so
we'll take that ascent
agreed very much
uh so i now move to item number 19
any other items of business that the
chairman of
the committee decides are urgent and
there are none
so our name moved to item number 20
which is the exclusion of the public and
press
that under the section 108
brackets 4 of the local government act
1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one
of schedule 12a to the act and that
this satisfies the public interest test
could a member please second that motion
statement
thank you councillor durham
uh can we agree that via ascent
thank you very much so tara uh
i'll wait for you to confirm that uh we
are stopping recording
thank you chairman i'll just get
confirmation can we have a comfort break
please
we can have a comfort break so should we
have a five minute break